me
not many I could rings good yeah
actually literally literally everyone I
know doesn't use hey be careful are just
under I got zero downs I think you don't
have a gun yet oh [ __ ] like oh I just
got this guy got killed by someone else
Green isn't working well people don't
like you no sorry
I got rid of it I don't care it on go
ahead
[ __ ] go ahead [ __ ] I'm gonna
race down so just not play with these
guys
mm all right Coco yeah I'll put I'll
play a bulgur and Wesley sent me an
invite beautiful they're all back
everything right back down oh absolutely
match oh damn is 7999 already in find me
when you get a chance Boulder did I get
a kill oh yeah I only have four kills
Jesus Christ how many killed did I get
it
oh my god I have four kills just not
good look nice good [ __ ] Wesley Pipes 15
kills beastmode 15 kills I'm on 18 kill
y'all four kill total streak but we need
a third
I was good at forget to use your super
it's a it's a portal don't in the
YouTube Kraig stride to say if you want
to rent me for $50 I know guys I'm sorry
I want to play with a controller and
paper yeah
[Music]
I hear you there Petraeus went
I'm getting a better camera everything's
gonna be jeopardized don't worry because
[ __ ] why do they have an old-school
logitech that I found in my closet just
like a 1998 first we'll talk later you
thirty first webcam ever
[Music]
all right as xud let's go all right I'm
gonna just I'm just gonna follow code
peanut I mean watch them take everything
that I want so I get to follow because
they don't follow him he will disappear
on on us first
be ready be ready
how'd you get home I got this is what
I'm talking about right now he just did
it right now I went into this room first
but he just comes [ __ ] running in
snagging [ __ ] who could be terrible for
like like if you go on Halloween if you
go on Halloween with him he just takes
all the candy just like trick-or-treat
and he just comes running in he's
already gone like he's not even like
he's like he's playing solo let's go
where's this [ __ ] I think we can get a
win
maybe mean coke won yesterday god I need
a win did we who was on her you know
we're just already [ __ ] this room we
[Music]
focus a thief
they know that really and a watch would
you would you rather which I'm rather a
gun actually kill somebody or miss you
see what I'm saying that's the kind of
[ __ ] I'm talking about right there
does that sound like a good teammate
does that sound like a motivation does
that sound like a motivational speaker
to you guys is it a motive let's go I'm
coming
Jesus you think you're helping with your
leadership oh my god oh my god
I'm joking geez calm down Smurfette
would not be the leader of the Smurfs
[Laughter]
what's this do I need that nope I'm just
afraid you're pretty far out what's this
don't need that god I can't find a good
no what am i doing you need a scope yeah
no I need an actual like primary gun I
got a [ __ ] pistol in this sniper
rifle oh there's something over here
dude there's a SMG oh what's that some
change what one isn't wait let me go
back market I forgot it's got two
compatible attack Oh market god I just
used my super by accident how do you
mark [ __ ] again what is it oh I need
this [ __ ] yeah give me that helmet
alright now I'm good to go we're going
to this we're going to this compound
over
[Music]
like everybody is playing this game it's
dude it's so big right now
yeah that's taking that who took that
enemies
are they on you why do I need that mo
don'ts know so if there's no gun listed
it means that I can use this ammo let me
see this drop it drop it I get it now I
just learned something about it wait how
do I get out of this building
what's dispensary
people ask how that wasn't you don't
don't read the chat griffin they're
being negative yes they are negative
lies Volger another team pieces of [ __ ]
oh my god this is like team after team
I'll take that I have a Supply Drop you
when you call it oh no because that's
does that everybody think there's still
one more thing getting on damn right I'm
doing that American Idol anybody need
health yeah do they do they already got
its whooping for its ass oh sure man
what the hell cuz it just looks miss
Roza prettier it's a prettier game or
and its first it's it's it caters and
like anybody in here do I want this guy
instead of this I just I just died I
gave you that lose my for everybody
am I gonna win with your [ __ ]
negativity
all right yeah but us so you know my god
no you need other people better players
to win I don't know how to get up why
can't I climb up there
I can't
I did look up I'm just coming around the
mountain here we go Here I am help each
other out
no there's no help no efforts will be
like that's our coke oh [ __ ] we got to
go
here also someplace was a good kill good
hole
yeah exactly I'm making sure nobody
comes up behind I know when you're the
[ __ ] bully you're the bully who's not
even trying to help the fat kid you know
I mean you'd be dead you'd be gone
you're alive you like life yeah
take this knock-down shoot so when you
get down you live longer
all right very good I think that I love
me all the way back seven more teams yes
you want it already had one that is
better what do we do we going around the
Malibu this is it don't worry for my
first win we leave properly but I tell
you chat is judgy at least where I can
smoke him there's one there and there's
one here that's a great idea
one of them jumped into the water off
the bridge
someone took damage oh man we gotta look
down there my hair down there oh this
[ __ ] ring oh I see I see what you're
saying oh my god oh my god oh my god
can't jump Thank You Pikachu with some
encouragement you know now you see a
team leader like Darth Vader a frosty
their fight minute left I had one but
I'm firing me yeah you're so far out
into the laughs yeah all right here come
slide are we gonna chilling here are we
going what's shown here supposedly all
right I'm coming we're a dummy all right
here we go this is good up - am i right
I love you the cover saying conversation
cover hit the car I got ready for
watching Griffin hold on don't forget
subscribe the worst party member oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
yeah he did say stay frosty I know it's
ridiculous okay guys here we go
I mean a hundred thirty people hey watch
that door I'm gonna watch other door
with okay oh you want me to watch the
door by myself okay that make sense well
you got a shotgun you're good
alright bulgar have less you know you
say that no I got one guy there's
another guy I don't know where he went
I just killed one of them let me return
yeah I'm kind of like weird shotgun have
some kind of weird I got I'm good
oh you get to charge it up does it shoot
better when you charge it up cuz that
would have suited me [ __ ] there's a
guy over here my god they're there is
she like shoddy the body
you don't know what stay frosty means it
means like stay ready you know like that
ready be a cold-blooded killer
Oh what what what was that oh [ __ ] you
scared me
Griffin Griffin don't aim down sights
that that noise we can hear oh so let's
just wait till somebody comes but we
draw him in blast him in the face we in
the circle okay we're in a circle all
people are definitely gonna come here
shoot right guys there's only four
squads left 12 people I got some 12 you
come down to my left incredible
you might see it right first wind is
happening right now who thinks so chat
[Music]
don't forget to ping buzzy it's very
weapon
Check Into chair what are we doing I
need anyways yeah you have any extra
heavy ammo like excess heavy ammo I
don't
oh she scared me I know what the bring
closes so now we're we're about to see
people right
who's calling I can't I don't know that
more unlikely we'll see there's people
fighting up at that that base up top to
the squads I was [ __ ] boys like hurry
up and win test like I'm literally just
waiting ok now if you play like me gaff
I mean how we can't can you hear him
he's gonna be father-of-the-year man i
swear to god you're not talking [ __ ]
you're for sure talking [ __ ] they're
coming in what's going on
stay frosty
marking up surroundings
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
we're okay close this [ __ ] got it where
should we go
oh there's a good gun right here the
doors bro I can't hear you where you
sent 100 percent okay yeah yeah yeah he
looked 100 percent over do you need
health yes no I'm good follow me wait
wait for me Jesus Christ you can just
[ __ ] take off give me some warning
yeah I'm looking at the other side to
make sure we don't get oh my god I'm
outside and you guys are inside oh my
god because because I did where are you
guys okay well I'm in here dude I'm
gonna come upstairs I think it's better
come up here dude this is a good spot
right here are you guys I can't even get
to you I cannot get underneath oh my god
how to [ __ ] these guys do smoker to your
left you're going to the right why don't
we open with this is not a good spot oh
we're not
[ __ ] shout you guys are so on-brand
no Jesus Christ he's above us
oh [ __ ] what was that oh [ __ ] right
there pipes oh my god getting rid of
that we're left
oh [ __ ] only two squats
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god how do you
[Applause]
show you Spidey teleport super mouth
well I feel like for grenades we're not
in the circle huh we got to move forward
to be in the circle we should we're
gonna wait 234 seconds right oh I guess
we're not gonna wait 234 seconds I'm
following oh my god this is this is
nerve-wracking yeah it was to squad is
getting this [ __ ] close this door so
close this is it y'all
yeah we got [ __ ] water maybe meeting
are we in circle
yeah okay they gotta come in here right
who else is in here just six well just
another house Jesus Christ okay this is
it everybody stream this energy good one
for my first oh [ __ ] I'm out of this
moment I'm not in the circle oh my god
she's disgust I wasn't in the circle
this way I'm feeling I'm healing I'm
healing he's over here follow me
okay okay I'm switching to the medic
[Music]
just control out here boys just stay
alive
he's over here there's a guy over here
inside the building alright alright
alright okay okay okay
you shoot whoo shoot just give him my
shields every charge okay I want to go
in this this is the run behind him
destroy ring closing no no I'm a
teammate oh my god let's say we've done
two squads left
watch out this who did that
I hate this I'm taking this oh my god
down where is he
keep coming over here right come on
right here there's already one squad in
there outside look at me what if I go in
vis winning the room I shoot him with
the shotgun try it
[Music]
one kill the fighting for my plan
I wanted theirs and when I shot the [ __ ]
it's not good you know give me no credit
Wow the whole time you got a hundred
okay okay just to say good job
Wow Wow Wow the [ __ ] worst [ __ ]
worst yes I had to revive him like three
times
oh my god you said not to let him die
thanks to my final kill thank you he
doesn't know how to be supportive he's
the worst
everybody knows Pikachu drives me nuts
and I said he did a good job he did do a
good job you got over a thousand damage
yes I got a milla milla for the wind
good job yeah the hundred they counted
you know you only as good as your last
game I did it thank you chat for the
support filing the essence of
going for my second win thank you very
much thank you for witnessing live I was
clearly the MVP of that win so thank you
for noticing that chat I was very much
like very much like Kyrie Irving in
their finals when when when Kyrie Irving
he hit the final shot you know what I
mean to win the championship LeBron got
all the credit but currently I'm the
Kyrie Irving of that victory right there
so thank you very much for funny fingers
and when we when we show this on our no
I'm just gonna edit that part out what
they're gonna see is their their final
kill some credit I don't know why you
get and go thank you
coke is a sore winner isn't he he's like
the Saurus winner you know what I mean
like I mean it's like wow he can't just
be like you know good job Griffin you
know besides the final kill right that's
besides that right first of all he took
you down three times so yes it would
have just been me and he might have
killed you because you were being a cuz
you were being a [ __ ] hiding behind a
tree you were hiding behind some sort of
like stalagmite I just want to say good
teammate okay finally I think it matter
do i chat what do you guys think did it
matter you know the you know the chat is
saying it he was
scared everybody everybody cz how you
were scared there like you were scared
and you were like hiding behind the just
alag my you know I mean that final blow
what you guys think
really what do we do this is what
happens you know because this his
fearful gameplay is the reason why the
game wants him how yeah well that's
because I needed to I needed I needed to
be behind and make sure that you know
people didn't come I was keeping track
of the flank
get out of here where do we get out oh
there we go there we go there we go
thank you thank you to the chant the
chant is spoken I was aggressive and
murder I had a good wasn't that a great
plan chat winning vis went around but
they know when they see a champion in
action they know sore winner
grief this guy would win an Olympic
medal and then push the other people off
the thing you know he pushed the silver
and bronze like right off the podium get
out of here you know I mean but thank
you for watching chat the chat is with
me it was a great flank it was a great
shot II
let's let's you're nothing that's really
hit one bullet again just do we love you
okay this all I care just do what you do
and let me do me okay be supportive
piece of [ __ ] the worst oh my god
all right let's see if we can get back
to back back-to-back wins well we got my
first win first win oh that felt good I
haven't even got a first win in Call of
Duty I never even get you notice that
but I contributed okay no I haven't got
a Call of Duty win that one kill y'all
that's the killer champions you know I'm
saying you're only good as your last
kill right guys you know this is the
best thing in the chat
check out this chat message coke just
shut up and carry that completely just
shut up and carry okay five kills y'all
five kills I don't know well let's see
this make it happen go let's go here
let's go jump master
sir I need I mean thank you I had to
revive Pikachu like 17 times the chats
are you know really did I not have to so
I should have left our teammate dead
does that sound like a good teammate
y'all I should have left him dead just
say it I should have left him dead right
well I'm a good team no man left behind
dude no child left behind
okay that's my theory right there right
that's how I play you just come running
up on my you know my area would you want
product selector up here oh my god I
just have a grenade this is so
infuriating
you can take the Peacekeeper oh yeah oh
I just did a dope jump please keep on
yeah
get your peacekeeper Oh some more ammo
now I need the I need a joke there's a
devotion right over here is keeper okay
if we see light machine gun nests boys I
got two good guns I'm
we got some barrels over here too okay
okay yeah I got my drop coming yeah I'm
gonna drop my drug it just over here sup
yes no I don't need that wait yep get
rid of that see now I'm starting to see
how to shoot huh really
okay I need course they are a number one
sign there's two there's two say I'm
Scout and that's what my character is
man this guy oh my god to sign this
piece of [ __ ] check out there's two
there's two legendary legendary thinks
they're in the shotgun and make make it
a shoot better yeah never on the wall
guys we're going back to back like drink
yeah
wait I didn't see did I pass them oh I
think there's what ultimately so no keep
doing or Pikachu this you are all to no
one
no I don't want I just need some scopes
oh I see I see I'm coming okay here's
some shooting guys I have sixteen seven
bola oh no I think I have you gotta get
a sight for though oh I have a scout a
g7 scout is that a scout rifle or is
that but only shoots ten it has ten in
the thing okay do I need to oh [ __ ] I
could take that lowly poor though give
me that
alright have enough grenades oh wait let
me see
but at worst fireteam watch out coming
in this guys coming in reference gonna
clutch it out hey I killed the guy
outside by the way all by myself you
were supposed to be scouting okay see
285 damage one kill so you know just
coming off that last victory zero kills
to code 90 damage so do it if you would
use your gun maybe you wouldn't died is
all I'm saying
the chat is talking right let me just
leave that on the screen right now one
kill ok I did try to go lookin a that
was a mistake
ok decided no I did wait out of ammo ok
I shot my gun ok
everybody so he missed all your bullets
yeah oh man no I shot him but he had
like a shield man [ __ ] I know guys I
know a point-blank shotgun would have
been better than a thermite grenade I
agree
guys I completely agree but I [ __ ]
ran out of you know bullets enough you
know I should have used my invisible
[ __ ] that's what I should have done
I forgot my move I forgot my big move
guys Jesus Christ that was all me you
know what I'm taking that loss y'all I'm
taking now it's so kind of
this is gonna be a good fight
I just need a
this is your champion lesson I'm sure I
can get where we going
oh we're going to go here and we're
going to go straight to Thunderdome
four teams left
here's a site
okay okay oh [ __ ] no guns on this [ __ ]
right here we go here we go okay oh I
got my combo already I don't know up top
where you're shooting my god they just
it's terrible when your own teammates
like loot everything before you can even
get to it kill me okay I don't want this
stupid semi it's actually pretty good
thought it was one of those shotgun ones
no shotgun once suck all right you guys
want to move up we got to move up
together yeah I know all right don't
don't there's a guy right in front of
you coming up behind you guys oh this
guy have these guys gold [ __ ] already
we were lucky with that one coke listen
I just want to point out again the one
kill because you couldn't finish the job
I had to come in and handle it you know
the minute walk somebody had to kill so
they don't shoot us I'm just saying I've
gotten three kills in a row since my
finishing kill I've gotten three kills
in a row I'm just doing thank you guys I
just want to thank everybody in the chat
for supporting me I really appreciate
the support and love because I can't get
it from my friends you know what I mean
so I just want to thank I want to thank
you chat for being there to support me
in this endeavor I really appreciate
from day one you know chats been every
day one you know but we're counting went
we're counting the kills now y'all so
Griffon up three we just don't count
these MVP kills I won't thank everybody
for watching live super chat if you want
a super chat at any time I totally love
that support for the victory that
victory super chat would be great
we have no choice but to me uh uh well
there's you can you guys advice with
them no I do care I look with my how's
the bike sound other ones that might you
instead
your mouth
[Laughter]
Seanie other teams
nope
yes
from arctor no I don't know
the hell are you talking about you don't
know like I don't see anybody else
next see anybody over so we got the
whole [ __ ] that's how we won the last
game Spitfire baby I was a contribution
Eric Cooke's greatness smoke he doesn't
do that anymore hey there's oh are you
shooting that wasn't me in front of you
it was Griffin oh yeah
oh yeah yeah they're taking the zip line
the coke I'm calling for a new fire team
anybody out there that's gonna carry you
the whole way someone can do it with
like a little bit of more grace someone
better customer service skills yes such
a great job thank you so much hey
Griffin
they said they can barely hear you on
your stream
[Music]
turn my mic down now can you hear me now
it's only one you yell your cue
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I'm so far okay these guys are
so are you guys in that cave yes bro
we're I'm gonna hit these canapés real
quick right up here yeah yeah I'm coming
[Music]
[Music]
oh there's a lot of [ __ ] here there's a
scout playing principle then have you
know oh my god
if you see any extended heavy mags let
your bro know I hear some shooting
guards oh there's none of us you want to
spit fire
I mean do you want this um cheese keeper
have the attachment for it dawg no no I
don't who is it on you got one down I
don't need this and then drop smoke do
you write I have a I like this gun I
have well then get rid of this girl what
you're not gonna use a sniper rifle
Griffin oh this is yeah there's heavy
Apple right over here guys guys are
getting left man
I know I know what I mean I was trying
to help Griffin get better guns he's far
away oh my god those circles gonna touch
us for hold why don't regret it and do
your LBD or LV
you're fine I am Akhil may you see my
here you see anyone right in the circle
I'm Way over you not yet but I'm staying
low here
I need you to grab that roof for fun
don't worry about your help I'll heal
you when we get to it oh my god can I
get in the [ __ ] circle here we got
man Amanda Oh frustrating okay
do we want to take this redeployment
yeah make it up to me
redeployment now see you cope
speak it up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we got to get the coke now
let's go let's go
rotate rotate rotate dress their [ __ ]
god damn sad beefy nine squads left
we're good oh [ __ ] are they going ham
all right um
what the [ __ ] is happening right go
don't go too far head
oh nevermind who's that no that's coke
Oh somebody left their [ __ ] [ __ ] here
what is this sniper nobody needed that
you go hit the care package then go get
that let's go sorry guys
gamer goo okay he's super goo right
actually I wish I had some game oh yeah
tiptoe Griffin um we actually we could
do a giveaway and then they will ship it
for us to the fan so I have it dude I
have some heavy rounds I can drop that I
don't need I'll give it to me giving me
a Spitfire thank you
focus hell up quick doesn't make any
sense
all right we're trying to go for win two
in one night y'all
that's like what we're trying to get
people what be yeah I need this ammo and
there's heavy energy arm ammo here and I
will take this let's keep this go behind
us trying to talk trying to cover our
ass here okay looking I don't see
anybody but there's people over there
was people over there though cuz all
this [ __ ] is open over here
heads up care package coming in care
package coming in on ethnic legends
legends what should be the name of this
yeah next time he sees you to give you
the game of goo packets it actually
legit works really losing it right now
yeah well there's a guy right here huh
me I'm her eye shadow we got a run bro
okay we made noise by shooting so
careful yeah that guy came out of
nowhere though like know what he was
doing that was stupid
be careful people could still come from
that zone just because it's he didn't
[Music]
let me see what purple [ __ ] he has me
this stay frosty stay frosty frosty dude
I'll take the telephone let's see the
circle of all my guys yeah I know but
the way down there dude we're gonna get
back and get okay it's fine no you can
have it already yeah here take a drop oh
so we're gonna be inside the building
the final circle is gonna be inside the
building shot already
hey do you have I have zero okay I'm
running both heavy I'm mo I'm guns
there's someone right here all right
let's go [ __ ] about me
I need I need some [ __ ] white ammo
though man [ __ ] let me see I have some
but then I won't have a slore amputee oh
I have a piece keep what are you guys
you had this it charged up watch it
that's not that's not pinched it is it
says light rounds
no that's shotgun less than 30 seconds
starting Sam oh I'm talking about a more
300 warp sorry squads left they're not
telling us how many people focus all
don't worry about looting anymore we're
good okay
all right here we go all right I'm back
what's trying to say no we got a win not
yet you got a win out yes because this
is telling they're gonna know where
we're at
yeah yeah cuz we already know where
somebody else is because of theirs okay
all right watch out coming from behind
though running through yep let's do it
let's do it let's do we got this we got
this play for reals I don't see anybody
comment
nope stay right here shadow make it you
don't poke ya Pikachu so they're nicely
there in the back oh sorry
I mean I'm let him read sir I'm watching
Griffin offices ring coming in oh Jesus
we got one minute let's just wait till
the end higher-tier Luke oh [ __ ] yep
we'll stay right here huh got a winter
saying that can barely hear Griffin on
his page [ __ ] okay where me trying to
help I already told him that I turned it
up nevermind nothing sure he probably
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
talking our chat Craig plugger podcast
yeah
great to talk about our chance they said
you better win that's how that was on
our chat about
okay we got this dude all right chef
they're fighting
should we go clean out a move rats to
our level let's go they have a Spitfire
on their team [ __ ] I don't have any more
grenades
they're just batter bell rings that's
you 545 let's go good oh this is it
y'all three squads man all they're doing
some serious damage over there he's
right there you see him follow me oh I
got a good shot on a guy don't shoot
them right here boys right here finger
I've got a grenade would [ __ ] kill us
that way if they try to run it we'll
have the shot on the back huh
okay this is it one more victory hey
don't do that make that all right watch
that left side Griffin yeah see anybody
coming trash will take a zip line when
they have to oh I see what you're saying
yeah yeah there's a zip line right here
just wait though let's see wait wait
round five all right it starts right
here right so let these guys let these
guys push we got a minute
all right nothing's no one's coming over
here on this side yet all the way they
probably would have been you know what I
want the guy will I want the guys on the
cliff to start finally towards him we'll
be able to catch them oh my god nervous
time I mean Oh Chet are you seeing this
going for my session take all that
give me your energy oh my god there they
are my dear
I see they they know where we're at yep
there he is
my do they use that [ __ ] scan thing
oh that's it I got my victory guys dream
is paying attention good third place
get over it or worse for our team and
thank you for watching
[Music]